you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
the scale of the environmental emergency
is laid bare as the earth's
vital signs show the impact of climate
change
how unequal access to covid 19 vaccines
could put the landmark cop26 summit at
risk
and the nature projects across the uk
getting a share of 40 million pounds
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions and the level of global
warming that's shown here on our data
dashboard is just
one way that we can see the rate of
climate change now scientists around the
world
measure the earth's vital signs and two
years ago they declared a climate
emergency
now those measures have been updated and
they show the emergency
is getting worse with more than half of
data points setting
new records over the past two years
glacier thickness is at a record low
level they're melting
much faster than thought losing 31
more snow and ice annually than just 15
years ago
oceans are the warmest they've been
since these types of records began
combined with ocean acidification at the
second highest it's ever been
the world's coral reefs are facing even
more damage
from bleaching and that's a significant
issue because
more than 500 million people depend on
coral reefs for food tourism
and tropical storm surge protection in
april 2021
carbon dioxide concentration reached 416
parts per million that's the highest
monthly global average concentration
ever recorded and research found farmed
animals such as cows and sheep
number a record 4 billion weighing more
than all
wild animals and humans put together and
livestock
accounts for about 14 and a half percent
of total greenhouse gas emissions
but there are signs of hope too
subsidies for fossil fuels
fell significantly as governments stop
supporting industries
such as oil and gas and move towards
renewable energy
well the research was led by a team of
scientists at oregon state university
including dr beverly law who joins me
now
welcome to you so your study found that
the majority of the 31
vital signs set new records so how
worrying is that
after covet you know we've had several
years of being confined and changing our
habits
and it really didn't change the numbers
if things just got worse 60 percent
of those variables got worse and how
close would you say we are
to tipping points those thresholds that
once
crossed could spark big and possibly
irreversible effects
well the most worrying thing is the loss
of brazilian forest
their loss has increased even more and
they are
really the workhorse of taking carbon
dioxide out of the atmosphere they're
the natural source or natural removals
of carbon dioxide out of the atmosphere
so that's that's a worrying worrying
thing and it looks like it could be
really close to tipping points you know
some of those areas could turn into
different
vegetation types and not before us
anymore
so what do you think needs to change to
try and alter those trajectories
well we've got to stop putting it off
you know we've spent 30 years not doing
much of anything
and now we only have 10 to 30 years to
make significant changes in reducing
fossil fuel emissions
just not using carbon-based energy
sources
and that includes bioenergy so that's
the first one and then
improving or protecting those natural
removals we call them natural climate
solutions
that's the land and ocean ecosystems
so we really need to tackle that now and
i just keep seeing like the national
u.s nationally determined contributions
don't say anything about protecting
the remaining intact forests temperate
rainforests
in the country were you
personally shocked at the findings of
your own report
yeah i was really hoping that that
because of covid people stopped and
thought about how they're living and
what their behavior has been and how
they've been able to get by without much
and so i thought that would be reflected
in the numbers but it's not
it's worse dr beverly law thanks very
much indeed
you're welcome in today's other climate
news a wildfire's
path of destruction through california
has been captured by a forest
camera the footage shows flames from the
dixie wildfire spreading through trees
before engulfing the camera itself the
dixie fire has burned through an area
bigger than new york city so far
and scientists say climate change will
only make these highly destructive fires
more common several towns on the shore
of lake como have been evacuated after
torrential rain
caused landslides and flooding across
the popular tourist destination
more than 60 people have been rescued
from the floods which filled the usually
picturesque
lake with debris the extreme weather
comes just days after
hailstones the size of tennis balls
damaged nearly a hundred cars in
northern italy
the high court has agreed to hear a case
brought by environmental campaigners
against the uk
government and the oil and gas authority
environmental campaigners say
tax breaks that cover the cost of
decommissioning which is the dismantling
and clearing old infrastructure
are inconsistent with britain's climate
change goals
mckayla lodge is one of the climate
activists who brought the legal
challenge
we're definitely not asking the
government to do everything overnight
we're just asking them to actually have
their actions be in line with what they
say
if they want to say they're a climate
leader if they want to say what they
want
is a climate just future then they need
to act in the same way
the iea the international energy agency
has recently said that we can have no
new investment in oil and gas if we are
to stay below 1.5 degrees of warming and
prevent
complete climate collapse and the
finalists for this year's welcome
photography prize have been announced
the prize includes a category health in
a heating world which explores how the
rapidly changing climate
can bring medical challenges the
category finalist
zakir hussein chowdhury's entry the
climate cost
shows a man salvaging his belongings
from the wreckage of his house
after cyclone anfan hit bangladesh
the crucial cop 26 climate summit
negotiations in november
could be under threat because of unequal
access to vaccines
the chair of the least developed
countries group told sky news those
most affected by climate change are at
risk of not being included in the
discussions well our climate reporter
victoria seabrook broke this story she's
here with me now so tell us more
victoria
yes so this week i've been speaking to
global figures that represent
46 countries and 1500 ngos around the
world
at cop26 these crucial climate
negotiations happening in glasgow in
november
and what they're saying is that
unequitable unfair access to the vaccine
is a threat to these negotiations
now the uk as hosts has said it's going
to try and vaccinate
anyone coming to glasgow who wouldn't
otherwise have access to the vaccine
but these organizations these leading
global figures are saying
that's sort of not the point because the
pandemic is still raging
globally we'll need 11 billion doses of
the vaccine
to end it for good and these talks
they're all about trust
and countries coming to the table and
saying yes we'll make big pledges
to cut our emissions and tackle climate
change in good faith that other
countries will do the same
so poorer nations are saying why should
we make these big pledges
when by the way we've done the least to
cause climate change in the first place
if you rich countries aren't playing
ball when it comes to access to the
vaccine
and there's also a moral question about
whether people like diplomats
although doing very important jobs
should be able to jump the cue ahead of
the vulnerable
in their population when it comes to
accessing the covered 19 vaccine
victoria thanks very much indeed now 90
projects across the uk have been awarded
government grants aimed at supporting
green
jobs and boosting nature recovery the
initiatives will each receive a share of
40 million pounds and range from
tree planting projects to restoring
wetlands
chester zoo will receive nearly one
million pounds to create
a nature recovery corridor we want to
connect
uh habitats for wildlife so habitat
connectivity is really important
it's one of the major causes for decline
in numerous different species
because habita so species need
they need a lot from their environment
they need food they need water they need
shelter
and they can't get that or they can't
necessarily get that depending on the
species in isolated pockets they need to
be able to
to move whether that's to to forage for
their food
or for other reasons well joining me now
is environment minister
rebecca powell now tell us more about
what kind of projects are getting this
funding and how they've been chosen
the green recovery challenge fund was a
fund set up last year actually the first
40 million pounds was
shared out last year largely to
environmental charities and conservation
groups and organizations
to do work to restore nature and also to
ensure
that jobs were either retained or new
jobs created
green jobs because there's a raft of
opportunities now
as we go and create many more
sustainable projects
for our nature restoration and for that
other side of the coin to climate change
which is
nature and adaptation so it's all about
kick-starting nature
recovery and tackling climate change as
you say and
welcome though that is there's still a
long way to go isn't there i mean the
government's own advisors the climate
change committee has said there's a
vacuum in policy
so when will we hear about those
policies that are going to get us to net
zero
one of the things of course we're
hearing a lot about right now and i've
been responsible for bringing the
environment bill through the house of
commons it's now
uh been going through the lords and it
will gain royal ascent by the autumn
well that is a
landmark piece of legislation that will
set us
on a sustainable footing for the future
and within that
we will be setting targets in air
quality
quality waste and recycling and nature
which will reset the dial
in terms of um we really am your
sustainable future
one of those targets we've said that we
will aim to
halt the decline of species abundance
basically nature
by 2030 that's a groundbreaking
and very bold target no other government
has done anything like this
we've also got of course our next zero
commitment
uh to achieve by 2030 and indeed we were
the first economy to introduce a law
to end our contribution to climate
change by 2050. so
there are a whole range of measures now
are coming into play and commitments
you've talked a lot about the targets
that are set and everyone agrees they're
ambitious
it's the action that we're not getting
is it we we need those policies when are
we going to hear them
those policies we're already working on
all the targets and
all the pilots are running around the
country to uh
to uh inform us of exactly how people
will put all these measures
into practice i've actually just been
out on a farm today in shropshire
meeting a farmer who's already sowing
cover crops he's
he's looking after the health of his
soil he's even still growing maize but
he's growing it through grass so you
don't get the runoff you don't get the
wash off
he's been growing his potatoes with the
whole border of physilius which is a
wonderful
flowering plant for the insects so
already a lot's being done but when we
introduce our new environmental land
management scheme now that we've left
the common agricultural policy we can
have our own policy
to tailor-make it to deliver these
targets
and that is going to be introduced soon
the first
bit of it is the sustainable farming
initiative
and farmers are already signing up for
that so we're already moving in that
direction
and yes there's an awful lot to do but i
truly believe
this government has the policies in
place now
for us to deliver on these targets and
actually we need to do it
okay rebecca powell thank you well
that's everything from us for today
next time what's the environmental
impact of a volcano eruption
you can find out tomorrow here on the
daily climate show see you then
you